[Applause]
can you break down the math
of how one spends millions of dollars a
year on their
uh lebron i think says he spends 1.5
yeah can you get me to 1.5
not saying it's a good thing like a bad
thing yeah
and honestly that's part of the
conversation right is they might be
getting overcharged for certain extorted
okay so break that down how are these
athletes getting extorted
what what are they doing why does he
even spend 1.5 what is that
yes i mean it's hard to argue with
lebron's approach number one right it
works
it works and he is the healthiest tenure
starter
in pro sports history 10 16. hey ten
you're in the sense that
like he has tenure like you'll just be
oh not 10 years yeah
like he is so you spend one and a half
sure
right he loses one and a half in his
couch cushions right yeah people are
extorting him and can live a good
lifestyle and his massage therapist and
all that great dude more power to you
because he's so valuable sure there's a
risk involved in taking that on
there's a risk involved in having him
because yo if he goes down
no not pointing the finger at him yeah
who's a massage therapist who's his
acupuncturist who's this who's that
so like people are and he's really
spearheaded that number is circulated
and he's really spearheaded the
initiative and kind of getting these
guys thinking now about the investments
like yo if i spend one and a half a year
but he what was his contract in l.a 137
million
stupid gonna be a billionaire if he's
not already
right so so it's like if you if he can
pay out
1.2 and then he can extend his career
by seven minutes oh there's your
1.2 there's no question whether it makes
sense what's i think a lot of people are
curious
about is how do you spend one point
right like just what are the jobs that
you're hiring like
i mean i don't know like for sure i know
he's got like his own personal strength
coach
and what would that go for for a year
this person travels with you
man depending on kind of personal
relationship he has with him depending
on how long he's been with them like a
lot of these guys still have a dude from
high school
100 000 honestly 250 000
man if he's trying to write up [ __ ] from
his taxes he'll you'll throw that guy
some extra cash right like if it's a
right off it's it's a business expense
so there's not a real price for it but
it could be anything from
low six figures to mid six figures i
mean think what you're asking for this
guy to do
right like travel with you everywhere
you go where you go you're his shadow
but you're also building his career and
you're gonna be lebron's guy and the
second you come out the other end of it
that's where you're writing a book
you're doing whatever you want yeah
so okay so you have your strength and
condition strength and conditioning
coach
they're going to have some massage
therapists is almost a guarantee
so just a masseuse this guy just
massages you or this girl just yeah
okay and those times those ancillary
services are usually like on a fly-in
basis i find so like
they don't travel strange coaches
especially when you got a guy like when
you're
someone's guy especially at the nba
where it's like the strength
conditioning culture isn't what it is in
the nfl strength condition coach is a
position that's uh that drives culture
in nfl like that's a position where the
teams are going to hire for for 17 weeks
like for the guys that i work with in
the off season for most of them
we're just going to exchange hands with
the strength coach in that team
and then for that 17 weeks they're there
i'll still consult just because
you establish kind of a relationship
with friends with these guys when you
work with them in the off season
but so for a masseuse that's usually a
fly-in role like
maybe once every two weeks or hey i'm
going to be close he'll fly you in so
then you got to pick up the expenses
like yo you're going to pay her
probably on a salary when you go i want
you here this is the whole concierge
market
i'm paying so that your practice you
have all that [ __ ]
stops when i leave you need to go and
they'll schedule it out but like yo
i went down in the third quarter that
that that phone's going off
you got to know that like your office is
closed the next day and it's also
possible a guy like lebron could just
have a
24 7 masseuse on call sure okay at his
point like he's probably not but if
you know lesser guys who are trying to
emulate this model i find the massage
therapist is usually one that they're
sourcing in a city or they got something
they like and they fly in
how much you think just destroying
watson paid for massage coach
son if you paying six figures i'm
getting the ancillary service you're
talking about
you're about to pay a lot right yeah
i'll tell you that much
okay um so we've got strength coach
massage
physical therapist or chiropractor
probably another ancillary service they
probably stick with the team
nutritionist is probably going to be
where they spend a decent amount of coin
personal chef personal chef and that's
usually going to be one thing
okay nutritionist and personal chef one
thing usually
it can't be two and they just coincide
as a as a unit like that's gonna be
something where they're running blood
work they're kind of seeing where your
deficiencies oh [ __ ] okay
optimization we're talking six million
dollar man here 137 million dollars yeah
right so it's like
they're going all in and that becomes a
logistical expense you need to get his
food
sourced cooked prepped ready in his face
when he's got to be somewhere
yeah right so that's like those are the
big ones that oftentimes that they'll
hit
what about cairo physical therapist
oftentimes sourced by the team
depending on what the player's viewpoint
is around those services they might have
their own guy and i think this is where
the tab gets expensive
is by having so many people
so many cooks in the kitchen that don't
have crossover they don't have crossover
whereas like somebody hires you right
you are strength and conditioning you
are
cairo cairo you are nutritionist
for some guys yeah i'll take over the
nutrition as well i work with a guy
masseuse kind of falls in the manual
therapy stop biting your bottom lip
please uh
he kind of gave me a miracle therapy
thing but yeah so it's like
and here's the thing and this is kind of
like when i speak with prospective
athletes about like working into a
season it's
there's you can be 70 like say the
lebrons guys are 100 the best in the
world the best strength coach the best
chiro the best masseuse the best
nutritionist the best
chef whatever but if there's no
interconnectivity
between these these moving parts if the
input doesn't talk to the output
like if i don't know that we're gonna
have like a purposeful overreach in his
training
this week and i'm the chef and he's
still getting
i don't know 3 300 calories it's like
that those have to match
you can have the best you can have you
know bobby flay or whoever the [ __ ] is
his chef and you can have
i don't know i'm sure his guy is good
yeah you're not even working out this
week but we're still feeding you like
you're working out right that's a
problem
right or no like we're you we're working
out crazy and we're feeding you
like right now bigger problems right
either one yeah right so like inputs and
outputs
need to be managed and this is where
like then also you can have like you
have a data scientist
right you could have a data scientist on
staff like hey we're gonna monitor your
gps we're gonna hook you up while you
play which is a really common practice
yeah like how many miles did you run
this game
right yeah if this team stretches out
your career
one year right you've made
100 return on your investment oh without
a doubt because if you're spending a
million a year
for 12 years right and you're making 30
million a year or 24 million a year
whatever the [ __ ] he is
right and you just get one more 24
million you've paid
everybody and you've made double the
money but there's a flip side of that
okay
what if you get hurt well the contract
is guaranteed in the nba though so
yeah but well this is a really
interesting conversation that's really
topical right now because
you guys familiar with juwan james no
john james plays for the denver broncos
now he's out 10 million dollars because
he's tore his achilles in the non
uh a non-authorized facility oh yeah
yeah which is y'all like
you know that's kind of what i do right
like i work with guys it's like i don't
work for an nfl team
yeah but i work in the offseason it's
like they're your property of a team
they have your rights and they can trade
you and all that [ __ ] but you're not
getting paid
yeah you get paid once that first once
you flip the coin now you're starting to
get paid yeah right so it's like once
you report to camp or you go to otas
they're gonna start throwing you some
scratch but you're well that's a you
problem so it's like you got athletes
that are trying to train in the off
season
to improve their skill improve their
craft to buy for every new position to
put up better numbers and get bigger
contract
they want to have someone you know
procure this for them and take care of
this for them they know like yo i'm good
at catching the ball
i'm going to run in the ball i'm going
to tackle guys i'm like a strength and
conditioning coach
i'm going to hire one and now all of a
sudden you hire this dude and we
accidents happen we know that and
hopefully it wasn't any sort of malice
or ignorance that led to that injury but
you got a guy right now that's not going
to make 10 like
there's an internal memo that went out i
got my hands on it last week
through the players association warning
players like look
you're going to assume this risk and
juwan's probably going to be out 10
million dollars next year because
they're not going to pay for him because
he was injured and then not training in
their facility
they're doing volunt involuntary otas or
voluntary otas which is like
yeah that's kind of [ __ ] up because he
just comes back out into camp completely
out of shape they're going to be like yo
you're not in shape and we might not
even pay there might be some contractual
obligation for how much you have to
weigh when you come to camp right i know
a lot of the bigger guys have that
or you might just get cut so okay if you
don't work out in our [ __ ]
then you ca and you don't worry about
our [ __ ] and you get injured we're not
going to pay you right if you come here
and you're not on weight we're not going
to pay you there's a lot of caveats to
not get paid
and this is where european sports do it
right like soccer primarily yeah but
they do they just own raw material from
distribution it's like you're some kid
from
ivory coast that shows promise at the
age of seven it's like yo you come with
us yeah
where those two entities right now are
separate like you know we have hoa but
hoa
isn't uh a football team yeah right but
we can take
kids from high school and bring them
into combine
take them through the combine through
college into the league yeah but it's
almost like this changing of hands we're
in europe like no
this you know this is fc barcelona this
is fc barcelona what do you have six
this is fc barcelona when you're 20 and
you're making
and we this is our investment we're
seeding this investment by
having putting you through school we
have a school here here go to school but
also
recess is soccer right so that's kind of
the thing with the states and it's
dude it's no different than what was
going on in the ufc you guys were
talking about this a few weeks ago it's
like
what what do the fighters that fill up
the cards that
aren't good self-promoters what is their
tax
on those who are right right and it
becomes a numbers game
dude every owner in the nfl is just
playing that numbers game yeah right
it's like because you got these kids
going into the draft
every year pushing 40 times lower
pushing 220 benches higher pushing broad
jumps
further verticals higher and it's just
like oh
they don't even know that they don't
know names and i'm sure some nba or some
nfl owners are super diligent and care
but at the end of the day it's like
yeah you're gonna pay me yeah they're
making ems but these guys are
billionaires yeah right there's another
guy waiting for juwan james's job and at
the end of the day
that that piece on the board is filled
for that owner yeah you don't care man
why would he change it